millions of people are traveling for
thanksgiving despite government
officials urging them
to stay home amid fears with cases
skyrocketing
nationwide the health care system could
be overwhelmed in the next two weeks
experts say dr marty mccary
is a physician and professor of public
health at johns hopkins
and a fox news contributor dr mccary
great to see you dr
krutika kupali she's an infectious
research
disease researcher at the medical
university of south carolina says and
i'm quoting i'm a little bit concerned
we might start
seeing things on a scale of what we saw
earlier this year in places like china
and spain and italy could things get
that bad
following thanksgiving do you believe
well look i think we're going to see a
series of rolling increases the trend is
not a good trend i don't think we have
to worry about a mass
spike with rationing at the doorsteps of
our hospitals
like we were concerned about back during
the days of new york in march and april
but look people need to take this thing
very seriously 90
000 americans right now today julie
are in a hospital because they are
having trouble breathing
or are in very serious condition because
of covid so
we're adding as you said about 170 000
new cases a day but we're only
diagnosing about one in five to one in
ten
that's about a million new infections
per day so people
do need to take precautions
you know the lines at covid test sites
are also increasingly long and it takes
longer now um for lab results to come
back you know the quest
tests that people used to get back in
about two to three days and now are now
taking up to five and that certainly is
going to complicate things
as we see rates of cases skyrocket the
delays in getting those results back
is also an issue how much should people
heed this warning then
to stay home considering if you are
exposed your test results
are now delayed the same way they were
back in the spring of 2020.
well i think everybody julie needs to
assess their own personal risk we knew
that this infection
had its death or mortality skewed
towards co-morbidity but we didn't
realize
just how skewed it was and in fact when
we talk about those with advanced stage
being at increased risk
it's really because advanced stage is
linear or
co-linear with comorbidity so look
testing is strained
uh but we don't want to be requiring
every basketball player
to have two tests in order to play
that's the those are the lifestyle
testing
things that are clogging up the system
right now
yeah there's a lot of companies actually
that are testing employees three times a
week my own sister actually
gets a test three times a week and i
know several others um
in the production business that are
having this my question is you know
might we be seeing these same
holiday driven spikes in december and
into january this may be just the
beginning
i mean we people are coming up are going
to be celebrating christmas hanukkah
kwanzaa new years
and and it rolls out um and in that
vaccine by the way that
the president has said the warp speed
vaccine is supposed to be coming out
sometime
possibly uh by the new year and and some
experts have said this could be wiped
out by
may does any of this seem realistic to
you
well first of all i think it's important
not to have one single blanket
recommendation for thanksgiving or
christmas our concern is when people are
not
taking precautions and they're high risk
look when we were telling people as a
medical community
to wash their hands like crazy we
probably should have been telling them
to wear masks
when we told people to stay at home we
probably should have said to be
outdoors and avoid indoor congregate
settings
so our strategy needs to evolve we're
likely to see increases in people that
are sort of in denial
maybe because of the mixed messaging and
the delayed clinical science
but i think people need to assess their
own individual risk
and the vaccine is very good news look
we were told
it's 95 effective in preventing the
infection but
what people don't realize is so far the
vaccine phase 3 trials
are showing that they are 100 percent
effective
in preventing death from covet that's
good news
and i think we're on track for march
april and may to be the months of mass
vaccination in the united states
let's hope so dr marty mccary thank you
very much
leland